this week complex on is in Moscow and my
guest is Vakhtang Kip she's a a senior
advisor to the Russian Orthodox Church
the clergy here are facing mounting
controversy over their hardline stance
on gay rights domestic violence and even
artistic freedom so is the church here
serving God or Putin
[Music]
vakhtang captured say welcome to
conflict zone thank you if the role of a
church is to serve God why does your
church seem to want to serve put in so
much this is a kind of myth that was
created by modern mass media our church
is different from its history and the
way she cooperated with the state is
quite different to what we have in the
West
first of all think it's a myth really
when when you're patriarch calls the
Putin era in 2012 Accord it a miracle of
God a miracle of God the Putin era
that's not a myth is it
this is evaluation and journalist who is
why he changes Putin's Church isn't it
but in church is something that is
construct this is Church of God and it
actually lives through different times
times of Stalin Lenin booting whomever
else but you are entering his policies
you are supporting his policies 100% we
support state as a Institute of society
that is true whether it's right or wrong
you don't differentiate do you what do
you mean wrong if you want and expect a
reaction from a church if it imposes
something immoral like for example
homosexual unions like in the West this
is immoral to support welcome to that
what about what about Syria your
government supports a regime in Syria
that has slaughtered tortured and
uprooted its population for the last 60
and here not to command what might know
better but your church supports that you
said Russia took a responsible decision
you called Syria a holy battle you're
identified and these poets are called it
holy battle yes you do
we we said that it is a holy holy
convocation to protect humanity from
terrorism so that's what
you supported it you have 100 Watterson
you should be wary action exactly's to
support the government in Syria Assad's
government what we not supported watch
what we actually support it is a
struggle against terrorism and we did
together with more very many religious
leaders from different traditions from
different churches mr. Kim should say
you supported a government that was
identified we by the United Nations as
being responsible for the deaths of
three hundred thousand people three
hundred thousand people where in Syria I
haven't seen these data yet thank you
ban ki-moon the last secretary-general
of the UN said that through a failure of
leadership Assad that was responsible
for the deaths of three hundred this is
a said not Russian government but you
support it 100% Russian government and
you support the Russian government in
turn so your identity lies with Allah no
government
we support state as I told you before
like a mechanism that is better than
cows and we did that many times
throughout Russian history because we
witnessed cows cows of revolution kales
of anti-church pressure during Soviet
period and we if you will repress Cal
community colleges that cows is worth
than state you know that you were
repressed by the communists or third yes
we were a present and now you're being
used by this government we you don't
seem to Larry or show any independence
well sure that is new to government this
is not the one that it is success in
successorship to the to the anti-choice
anti raishin used by the pyramid we are
not being used we cooperate with it we
even cooperate it with this we we even
cooperate it with the state what that
was actually anti-christian because
state is something that is that tries to
to support order in the society and as
you know the church that was fully
suppressed never had attempts to
submerse or just eradicate the regime
because that is not duty on this day on
the church in October 2014 your
spokesman Vladimir Legarda said do I
think that the state may try to use the
church for its own purposes probably do
I think we should be afraid of that no
there you are right in the pocket of
Putin's government and you don't even
mind it that what he said is quite true
because state actually needs the church
for the purposes of Education bringing
up so your political church no we're not
big political Church you talk about
Syria you talk about domestic policy yes
your political we are now speaking about
cooperation and what is used by whom for
what and it depends on very much
if church is used for the help of the
poor with the help of this stage for the
promotion of Family Values with the help
of the state we are for such kind of
exploitation if you want about church
but this is all we are not used for I
don't know for the struggle of lights or
for anything else that it is unthinkable
anymore of us let's put it this way
you've done well out of the Putin era
you've had 25,000 new churches you've
had a lot of churches renovated are you
afraid that you if you ever criticize
the government you'll lose some of these
new privileges you're afraid of that
aren't you I'm not afraid I am sure as
believer that our church will survive
anywhere anytime for all the riches that
the church has look at father o ciock in
rostov-on-don i mean he lives for
instance in a palatial house with an
indoor swimming pool your church has
become fat and rich and the
Putin hasn't it no our church is not
rich and it is not fat in 2011 in the
elections which were widely seen as
fraudulent several priests of the
Russian Orthodox Church spoke out
against the elections and they were told
by your authorities by the patriarch to
shutter one prominent Moscow priests and
Jesuits key was deeply critical of the
authorities he wrote as a result of the
particular way in which power is set up
in our society this arrogant attitude
towards the people has become the
abnormal Lord and he was slapped down by
the patriarch who said careless and
sometimes intentionally provocative
statements by priests cast a shadow on
all of God's church this priest was
being honest about what he saw why did
you shut him up because he went to the
policy and Church doesn't go to the
policy it it's not about the truth he
went to the truth didn't draw the
Egyptians a truth is something different
truth is how to save your soul how to
serve to the to those who need you it's
what you see in front of you is also
analytical check technologies it is not
about truth it is about political
technologies and Church doesn't want to
be a part of this political struggle
this is very very well developed and you
know this is decision that we actually
had to do just to bring and to to follow
it we don't want to be a part of
political games yeah you're fully
supportive also of the what what the
Russian forces did in Crimea the
annexation of Crimea you called it the
peacemaking mission that should
guarantee the Crimean citizens the right
to self-determination who said that this
was one of your your spokespeople I
haven't heard about that do you support
them yes your quote I will do do you
support that view our attitude is
totally different we we a single church
for Ukrainians and Russians and that is
why we don't care about
state borders we care about church
borders and church borders hasn't have
not been changed in Crimea mr. cube
should say you talk about persecution of
Christians in the Middle East and your
church has talked about the dangers of
that why do not talk about the
persecution of religions in Crimea after
your government went into Crimea and the
annexation the u.s. Commission on
International Religious Freedom reported
numerous raids on Muslim homes mosques
and schools and on Jehovah's Witnesses
which are now being banned and labeled
as extremist even here in Russia you
know are you happy about that sort of
that usually I don't command on what
they stay do in accordance with internal
legislation if they are they have
questions they should question it in
court and I think that my colleagues in
Islamic community could be a good
commenter's for that what has happening
there in Crimea because this is not my
business I am for freedom of religion
this is all and I think this free but
you've commented about the plight of
Christians in Syria you know that yes
but I had plight of the allegiance they
are Christians they are my brothers what
about Christian churches in Crimea by
late 2014 clergy who did not have
Russian citizenship including Greek and
Roman Catholics and those belonging to
the Kiev Patriarchate were forced to
leave Crimea well you know as far as
that's a crackdown isn't it on
Christians I think that was their choice
no it wasn't their choice that was that
they were forced they were forced to
leave don't want to live in a new state
that actually have jurisdiction over you
you should choose whether to take it
passport or leave the state this is
natural for any state they were forced
to live it's clear they were forced to
live I think but this is not my business
I don't know the details but I think
that they were firstly because they
don't want to follow the Russian laws
and Russian laws are effective there
whether we want that or not do you
believe that Russia is morally superior
to the West you've been very critical
about consumer culture in the West in
May last year you told your patriarch
told an American Bishop that even
through the Soviet era Russia was able
to preserve the Christian roots of
society here in Russia and avoid what he
called those ruinous processes which are
now unfolding in Europe and America do
you think Russia is morally superior to
the West I don't like they were the
wording moral superiority because States
living there all their own surroundings
and they fight this is normal for four
states to at least to compete and church
say that some moral messages are more I
would say relying on Christian tradition
and this is this as you talk about
ruinous processes in the West so
obviously you're holding yourself up to
you know totally morally superior unless
you know I'm very well involved in
ecumenical dialogue and I communicate
with my Christian brothers in the West
quite often and what we see is common
challenges challenges to to Christian
roots to Christian understanding of
family to Christian understanding of
society and to Christian the standing of
human being
and we with our brothers in the West
don't just say who is moral superior but
we want to address
koan challenges together and that was
very well reflected in the meeting of
patriarch Kirill and the Pope of well
let's let's be specific what you dislike
particularly in the West are gay rights
aren't there because in August 2013 your
patriarch declared same-sex marriage to
be a
sign of the impending apocalypse and
urge people to do more to combat the
rise of gay rights you said we must do
everything in our power to ensure that
sin is never sanctioned in Russia by
state law so you backed a law that bans
the propagation of a gay lifestyle
doesn't it that's what you backed you
support that what we backed because this
law actually had moral dimension because
we like Christians in all over the world
traditional Christians in all over the
world like Muslim people like Jewish
people like most Buddhist people
consider to be to consider family to be
a union of one woman and one man and
that is why everything which is directed
to eradication of this institute we
consider to be moral but by criticising
gays you turned them into second-class
citizens here in Russia we criticize not
gays we criticize seen you criticize
their lifestyle we criticize the sins
they commit but many gays and come to
hurt you turned them into targets didn't
you let me give you an example in 2014 a
gay activist from POV or ask a man
called Gleb latnok went to the police
after being attacked apparently on the
grounds of his sexuality
he had visible injuries he had bruises
on his face bruises on his eyes police
officer took his complaint and then said
to him you're gay so it's normal that
you were attacked why would you need to
file a complaint against anyone is that
the kind of normality that you want to
see in Russia we are against violence
against we are against violence which is
directed to any social groups including
those who are united by their gender
similarities but if you mark out one
group as sinners you can expect a
backlash can't you you knew perfectly
well there would be a backlash from
society against them we mark like
sinners very many groups like those who
drink too much those who are not
faithful faithful to their wives or
or husbands those who take up drugs
those who commit abortions we say that
you destroy your own happiness
those are pretty widespread sins in
Russia aren't they but this is perhaps
less widespread and so these people you
might as well have drawn a target on
their back for people to shoot that my
don't you
I don't mind justice well we put a dog
in a on the back against we don't make
any difference among thing am unseen if
you commit sin your sin doer despite
what sin you commit the other case is
that you want state to take your sin as
a norm that is why we against that that
sin cannot be a norm sin is something
that is abnormal
so you think gays are second-class
citizens
I don't I don't speak about their
citizens citizens rights are they not
worthy of petard
are they not worthy of protection by the
law in this gun
are worthy of protection of their rights
to security yes but they are not but why
do you not speak up because those rights
are being violated in Russia why do you
not speak up for those right I know that
is not quite true what you say when I
were to just act out favors with people
and we received very many letters of
those people whose rights are being
infringed by anybody by by bureaucracy
by other people O'Mara and we always try
to react to such letters I think that if
any person whose physical security was
actually violated would apply to our
church in his private letter we would
support him you have become extremely
unpopular with women's groups in Russia
after you back to man you're smiling
about this after you backed amendments
to a law that made it much harder for
women to prosecute violent and abusive
husbands where's your compassion
where's compassion in
Church of yours you know it is very just
schematic what you say about family
violence it is a very big story what I
can tell you is that we are against
violence in families but we don't want
state to control internal family life
State should support families with the
nation support people who abuse violence
and use up their wives you support that
and just because it's the way families
are you should support family education
you should support family training in
schools not sexual education but family
training so that no husband would ever
think about beating his wife but they do
you know that they do human rights what
way I guess that human rights groups
have said that as many as thirty six
thousand women and 26 thousand children
are reported to face violence in the
family in Russia every day it's a
reality isn't it you've just made our
reports you've just made it harder for
women to prosecute men who beat them up
so you want to protect the abuser and
not the vegetable that is not that is
not about you know eliminated
responsibility for violence you make it
harder for the women not for the women
we what we try to my Cara is into
external interference in family that is
our message that interference in family
should be an exclusion not you know like
you know you should just solve the
question in a different way you should
not just interfere interfere and
interfere in family
well his user should bring up woman a
women and men that is what we are
speaking about as a result of your
policy in 2016 a man identified by the
initials o be killed and mutilated his
wife and six children in Russia and
the mortar pieces with an axe over the
previous year his wife had appealed to
the police six times and the police did
nothing why because they said they
couldn't open a criminal case since such
incidents required a private prosecution
they couldn't do it she's dead
the children are dead they were all
hacked to pieces as a result of this
policy that you support this is not
result of this policy this case happened
before the changes to the law were made
but they were already saying that what I
already say totally and it's going to
happen more now isn't it as a reservist
I don't have we'll see but I think
anyway you're prepared to say simply
what we are speaking about care that
little about I don't care I am wherever
you I am very much concerned about that
and what I can tell you is that when
police officers don't react to what is
bad and what is illegal this is where a
big question to their moral moral
condition and I think that those people
who are indifferent to any troubles that
people actually face around him it is
very wicked person despite his police
officer or a simple person you seem to
be also supporting these days mr. Kip
should say a tighter version of a
tighter definition of artistic freedom
we've had groups in August 2015 we had a
group called God's will who invaded an
exhibition of underground Soviet art
that the Minesh exhibition just near
here
and smashed exhibits and said you cannot
offend Christ like that what do you
think of groups who perpetrate violence
in the name of God here we never blessed
them to do like that however we can
Fletcher knew they would didn't you know
that is totally an accumulator that if
you don't start identifying out sinners
and people no no
if you believe me that is I think a
point of trust
I can tell you that nobody now church
knew about this action before and if we
knew about this action we would try to
stop them however we think that the
masterpiece is how they call that that
was exhibited that were exhibited in
this menage building was at least
questionable from the point of their
attitude to believers and their rights
that is true but we are for peace
resolution of such cases in open and
sincere dialogue with the artistic
community this is our message and we
always say it in different fora people
who stand up against your church don't
do well do there I'm thinking of
citizens who protested about church
plans to build an Orthodox Church in a
park in northern Moscow for that
opposition they found them their houses
were raided by the police they were
forced onto the floor their children
were frightened early morning raids oh
because they stood up to your plants
because they liked this green space by
their houses and you wanted to put a
church on it and they objected to it do
you think that's good treatment police
forcing their way into families I
thought you didn't like that sort of
thing I think this very complicated
situation but we should just determine
choose 10 points from what we should go
first of all is that the allocation of
this plot of land was totally legal this
is one case that if you lost the battle
for this Indian you lost the battle to
win the church no we didn't lost the
battle we actually won the battle
because we say that this is our just
just of goodwill if you know the case we
actually decided not to build anything
on this plot of land I think almost two
years ago far before they actually had
these problems with police officers far
before and patriarchy and that was his
per
no decision decided to revoke this plant
to build their a church but what we
insist on now is that a cross should be
should be saved there because cross is a
symbolic thing and it actually poses no
no threat to the green grass or the
rights of the others you insist on it
whether they want it or not we are
insist on that because this is our
spiritual message that cross would not
be a threat to anybody backed
encryptions it's been good to have your
own couplets on thank you very much
thank you
[Music]
you